tem que comer cara porque o mundo
conspira para você não comer sua mãe não
quer que você coma Você já prestou
atenção que quando a mãe quer que você
não come as coisas ela inventa que não
pode comer você é criança Beleza vai
comer manga terminou de comer manga Ô
vontade de tomar um leite ó não mamãe
pelo amor de Deus leite com manga não
meu filho leite com manga faz mal mamãe
faz mal e ficar sem comer mano não pode
leite com manga não pode não pode porque
Reza a lenda de quem bebe leite com
manga morre Isso é conversa rapaz O cara
chega da lanchonete tem vitamina de
manga com leite eu nunca vi uma pessoa
que morreu de manga com leite oh meu
Deus o meu filho oh mulher dá o nome
bichinho então gente boa Oh coisa ruim
mulher morreu de quê mulher mulher eu
cheguei em casa só vi os casca de manga
um copo com leite no chão quebrado o
tanto que eu avisei mulher não bebe
leite com manga não desgraça também
Mulher tu cria vaca embaixo dos pés de
manga como é que tu quer que o menino
influe